quand j'étais petit je pensais que les
clubs qui auraient dans le futur ce
seraient les mêmes que dans le cinquième
élément
aussi je vous aime et vous m'avez pu
l'appeler comme ça tu qu'on a fini donc
là je parlais aux chats mais en fait
c'est ça une sorte de stylo plume la
première fois que tu vois un mec qui
fume une cigarette électronique du bloc
un peu parce que on a l'impression que
le mec qui lui fut un objet alors
contrairement à une clope normal la
cigarette électronique tu peux fumer
plein de goûts différents cafés des
fruits de légumes enfin bon il ya aucune
limite et il ya même des goûts de ville
vous avez pas vous montpellier non parce
que moi je fais une cuve du montpellier
vous avez pas il faut quoi les gens qui
fument du montpellier 1 il fume du
orléans je fus du rallye en moi j'ai une
tête à queue mais du orient je me bats
je me barre du madeira
si tout le monde se met à fumer des
cigarettes électroniques plus jamais on
pourra demander aux gens ce que tu as du
feu
ça ça n'existera plus pour recharger les
cigarettes électroniques
il faut un ordinateur excusez moi vous
auriez pas un ordinateur
c'est triste qu'il ya plein de gestes un
peu style et qu'on peut faire avec une
clope on pourra plus faire avec une
cigarette électronique comme par exemple
une clope
tu veux une cigarette électronique coup
pour charger une cigarette électronique
il faut mettre un liquide dedans
bon pas de panique il paraît que c'est
inoffensif d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on
peut lire sur le flacon inoffensif
en fait quand même une tête de mort ça
veut dire que c'est bon il n'y a pas de
problème célestin qu'est ce que tu fais
il était dehors dessus qu'est ce que
j'ai déjà dit s'il n'y a pas de tête de
mort sur les produits on ne boit pas ok
tu veux des crêpes
je suis vénère personne bien au moins
avec la cigarette
tu sais que tu vas mourir sans doute
d'une maladie qu'on connaît alors que la
cigarette électronique ne sais pas trop
trop ce que ça va apporter comme maladie
du coup qu'est-ce qu'ils vont écrire
comme petits messages de prévention sur
les paquets de cigarettes électroniques
fumer tue peut-être on sait pas encore
vraiment en fait ils se trouvent tous
les gens qui fument des cigarettes
électroniques
ils sont en train de se donner une
maladie supergrave que peut-être on va
découvrir seulement dans dix ans
mes yeux après dix ans d'études
on en a découvert que la cigarette
électronique ne proposait pas le cancer
par contre quelques effets secondaires 1
pas besoin de vous faire un dessin je
crois qu'on a tous compris
en tout cas on peut être rassuré marcus
je vois qu'on rigole un commentaire une
remarque à l'est champagne pour tout le
monde sans alcool bref comme on sait pas
trop si vous voulez vraiment être sains
de corps et fumer nous de cigarettes
nous cigarette électronique
par contre n'hésitez pas à consommer un
maximum de drogues dures à bientôt
[Musique]